well doesn't he may be able to change
their release schedule but it's now
nothing for us let's move it from the
studio that brought you the we are Siam
Esau Donald Duck's unfortunate World War
two adventures companies are we shooting
a man in the back piece and an Asian cat
playing piano with chopsticks comes
their stab at a Chinese folk tale about
gender roles now that's what I call
Mongolian barbecue Oh before you see
Disney's first actually justifiable
live-action remake someday revisit the
first time the mouse keep this story the
Disney treatment by smashing hundreds of
years of unrelated Chinese history
together jamming awkward 90 CG into
beautiful 2d animation and cutting
between a grim war story and the
fast-talking hijinks of a g-rated Eddie
Murphy what's your name chew I chew
cousin that that was funny now back to
the dead how many men does it take to
deliver a message widely meet blood
she's got the classic pretty princess
problem where she knows there's more to
life than this but where most princesses
think they need a man Mulan will cut out
the middleman and instead she'll just be
a man and while she's more inclined to
hug the patriarchy than smash it she
will kill a lot more dudes with snow
than Elsa ever dreamed of
holy crap this girl's got a body count
that could fill the Matterhorn
but luan isn't alone in her fight
against the Huns an evil race complete
with fangs claws yellow beady eyes and
good Lord Disney these weren't actual
people another yokai she'll be joined by
Mu Shu a tiny dragon workshopping his
donkey audition hey dragon dragon and a
supporting cast that's also challenging
stereotypes a gentle giant a cricket who
doesn't wear hats RC and a Chinese guy
who sounds just like Harvey Fierstein ah
where's my time hey in the 90s this was
what progress looked like at least it's
not playing piano with the jobs that you
always don't show it again but this kids
flick isn't all war in wieners it's also
about love wrap your arms around the
nearest pole and fall for li Shang
the handsome captain with the body of an
Adonis and the vocal chops of a Donny
Osmond
he's a little ping curious a little
mulan furious and very very shirtless
creating a passionate fan base that
demands an answer to just one thing you
have my trust
why does Lee Abbe nipples when Aladdin
doesn't a little nip consistencies all
we're asking for here at least make them
an option on Disney Plus so suit up for
a Disney movie that much like its Heroes
has struggled with its identity because
it was too American for Chinese
audiences too conservative for li Shang
fans and way too liberal for Vice
President Mike Pence but it still found
its place in the Disney pantheon thanks
to its bold heroine charming comedy and
a few memorable songs like the
stereotypically Chinese song
the glorified chant masquerading as a
song song
[Music]
you can leave them out in the lively
bank gets on the butt in the cartoon
[Music]
the no time to explain but Mulan can
fight now song
[Music]
still
to the training montage it go
Oh leaked by the time
[Music]
Oh
that's what
like this one are good
and the not-so-subtle coming out saw
[Music]
[Applause]
starring Ljubljana man true chorus is my
name I like the way you work it no
Germany's Chang sings in 1992 Shenmue
was an advertising executive in
Baltimore Maryland then for reasons
known only to him he left his wife and
career and moved deep into the forest
now he is only known as though Falconer
and realizing you got Mulan to thank for
Rick and Morty's worst fans MacDonald is
offering tender crispy chicken McNuggets
and a new Szechuan sauce for a taste of
the East big trouble in actual China
stop cheering you're gonna get bits of
pun in your mouth I did not have tasty
relations with that burger I'm saying
something original and epic in my epic
voice oh no everything's going according
to plan
I met death today we play chess help I'm
the one that actually writes these
things and they take all them